as the coronavirus dramatically impacts
the nation we've asked some fellow
Americans to keep a daily diary of what
they're going through
Joan Inman is an art historian she's
from Alabama Rebecca
chuta is a suburban Atlanta therapist
Rebecca's been offering free sessions to
health care workers on the front lines
christine savoir is a louisiana college
student she recently started a
non-profit to make face masks Oh
Christine and Martin groose is an
emergency room nurse he's from Detroit
here's a look at how they've all been
holding up my scrubs and I can help
others especially since the CDC
recommended that everyone who goes out
in public wear a face mask that leaves
it to people like me who can sew masks
to produce these masks for everyone else
I worked on the patio which has become
one of my new offices if the weather is
nice very tired assistant for also today
I took a very long nap which has become
the norm all which I love but also is
probably not the best habit I'm an ER
nurse at the only level one trauma
center in Detroit I just worked the past
two days if you can see in my face I'm
tired
and the reason I'm tired is because
myself and my friends or my co-workers
are taking care of some very sick people
I got her just
I'll be doing this expected sometimes I
feel like you care about your work more
than me that's tough this whole
situation has made things interesting I
am headed to the grocery store kind of
anxiety inducing no I'm just because of
the virus but because some people are
really racist
and I was gonna get into that now but I
think I'm going to wait I know the
infection can live in your body for up
to 2 weeks so I feel like a ticking time
bomb because like my dad falls into the
high risk factor since he's over the age
of 60 what if I were to accidentally
pass it on to him because of that I'm
gonna limit going home to my parents and
then we're doing a drive-by at my mom
and dad's how has this changed your day
to day life so with Asian Americans
being discriminated against right now
and it's very disheartening that people
let their fear get the best of them and
to allow themselves to be ugly to other
people because they don't know how to
handle what all of us are facing right
now so right now I'm making my very
first post on my new page called sewing
with savoir and I just hope it works
there are my kids playing some blocks
together today's been a little harder
than others my two and a half year old
is starting to get a little stir-crazy
typically on a Wednesday I'm off and I
go to play hockey well guess what that
ain't gonna happen
but it's good news too my dog Jasper
because now he's got the morning with me
Jasper up up up there we go
Mufasa My partner 9th or went to the
park which is probably the happiest I am
during the day I woke up and the page
that I started yesterday basically
exploded
the people that are messaging me are
like nurses or they're the parents of
nurses here the mess they have
and thank you for your donation with my
hours at my main job due to Co vid 19
and I'm on my way to interview at
another place and hopefully be able to
pick up a few hours my partner Mike was
laid off today he had worked there for
12 years so it was a huge blow today
ironically it also rained today so
didn't get a whole lot done
I was going to plant my beautiful lilies
that I bought on Saturday but was unable
to do that here we are and the local
parish and a kid way to those doors
opening it I think that we're
collectively suffering and I think well
we collectively start to experience the
same thing there is a certain kind of
bond that happens so yeah we'll see
where it goes from here
Oh a Marcin Christine Rebecca and Joan
we thank you all for sharing those
Diaries I think Tony it just shows again
the struggle is real I don't care where
you live what you do and how you do it
it's very difficult and part of the
problem too is that none of us know when
this is going to end at least if we knew
there was an end and what that was you
can mentally prepare but it's so hard
you can't even prepare yeah now that
that piece beautifully put together and
a reminder for me that this virus is
hitting the two places that people care
about most their health and their
finances if you don't have those in
order it's hard to pursue happiness in
this world and and as we just saw this
virus this pandemic is is ripping
through those two parts of people's
lives and it's a really scary thing
Anthony yeah and we heard people you
know talking about losing work as we've
been talking about in this show so this
is still coming at people it's not just
we don't know how long it's gonna last
but it's still coming at us in waves
it's it's really tough stuff